welcome back to Las Vegas now when area
15 opens in September you will
experience a place of wonder and
excitement unique shopping and dining
and plenty of art yeah JC is live with a
preview of their outdoor art hey JC hey
guys this is gonna be one of the most
Instagram mobile places in Las Vegas
once it opens up we're here on art
Island this is Winston and what are we
looking at here what's this piece behind
us
this is oma by alchemy arts it's as you
can see it's an owl that with brilliant
colors that's obviously swooping in from
above and it's just it's it's here I
mean it's a spectacular brilliant piece
the colors just pop and this is
something you would see at Burning Man
or life is beautiful instead of an old
warehouse you guys have it on display
yeah this is an actual and art gallery
here so while this is a place that
people can do events in the public and
enter for free this is for sale and
because otherwise this would be in a
warehouse and this piece does not go
anywhere I think if you're driving by in
the 15 you might be able to see some of
the stuff let's go through it we're
gonna do this we're gonna go through
this what are we going through this
trailer what are you guys ready for
there's any ship I'll let you lead the
way
yeah perception by Matt Ellison and he
designs amazing work and he wanted to
always build a large infinity ship it's
kind of psychedelic Carrie don't be
nervous come on all right all right in a
while this is it stress there's so many
of us but there's not somebody else yeah
it goes on forever because
now this is pretty cool and only walked
through the lights just gonna pop you
guys ready for this carry the weight was
it the dragon the fire-breathing dragon
oh my go first my friends people waited
buddy
no no we saw that dragon earlier what's
the backstory on the dragon what I mean
this is a piece that was obviously it's
again it was designed for customers and
he put out there and we had an
opportunity to grab it and it's
fire-breathing so we missed out of it
also but it's something that's just
raped and again otherwise it would be
safe it is so amazing I can feel the
heat to last pieces we get ready to wrap
it up here this metal object here what
is this is mech nine by toddler fuqua
and if you if you actually know he was
downtown we this was the first piece of
art that we had at area of 15 and then
we had him in the parking lot when this
was there was nothing here and then he
actually went downtown he had a home for
a while we were building area 15 and now
he's back here this is so cold now area
15 can open up in September our Islands
should be opening up as soon as we get
the OK from the governor as soon as we
get the OK from the governor we're
planned to throw an event escape to art
island we're hoping for August but you
know we call it a hoping a whole morning
I love it is so much beautiful artwork
here you guys are gonna love it when you
get to come down here for yourselves for
now let's send it back to the studio